I'm a single mom of four kids
and I post my content to encourage other women
to leave their shitty situations.
It's not you that's making your marriage miserable.
It's probably just your miserable husband.
I'm currently in a custody battle of my life.
I've already paid like $25,000 of my own money to continue this fight.
I have represented myself and won.
So, um,
I have done everything I can do,
uh,
my. On my own.
And I super duper need help.
And so if you just wanna click on the link
and look at this product that I just put on my face,
I think I did it wrong cause I put a primer on first,
but I need a primer.
But it is one of those Peter Thomas Roth.
Thomas Roths.
Or you could just look through my showcase and buy anything else
I need to pay thousands and thousands more to keep up this fight.
And so I appreciate the help.